in the physics department we had some
commodore pets and an
apple ii i think and a few other things
and you could play some
reasonably decent games on that i
remember space invaders on the
commodore pet that we actually managed
to hack and
change around if you knew the right
assembly when you moved across to the
sort of mini computer which we had the
pvp 1170
people were always a little disappointed
you know got my friends to come along
and say oh yeah look
at this we've got this big computer here
i say well first thing was four
games can you play on it and uh this was
the version seven which uh i did find a
um
a virtual machine for somebody made you
can actually all go and experience the
virtual 7 environment if you really want
to but it had a very
poor set of games really i guess that
wasn't really their intention in
making unix
they were all very much sort of command
line so it would print something and you
type something in and it would print
something else
sometimes you might get a screen full um
i think there was a
there was a chest but we never really
got going with that because that was
quite experimental at bell but there are
other things uh so if you're playing
checkers or something it would print a
board and
scroll up the screen and
obviously this was at uh early days of
computing and
the board rates were not very fast so
i think we'll mostly be on 300 board but
we still use
300 board for some things and that's
painfully slow is this like networked
gaming then
no this this isn't no this is just just
regular
connected to the computer so despite
talking about board rates this is
literally the terminal talking to the
machine that's right yeah we're so
used to i know wi-fi broadband super
fast broadband fiber this that and the
other that to go back to these kind of
baud isn't it board measured in the
hundreds
what does it what does it mean in terms
of say an ascii character well it's it's
really really slow i mean i've written a
uh a short term emulator to show you
what 300 board is
so if i look at the manual page for one
of the games arithmetic and i print it
or show it how it would appear on the
screen at 300 board
you can see it's a relatively painful
experience because you know it's
actually printing slower than i can read
it
so if you kind of get quickly frustrated
so that's 300
we didn't get very many things that ran
at 300 a lot of the campus ran at 1200
board though
so if you wanted to connect to other
machines or just
connect your terminal up to the computer
center that certainly ran at 1200
and that was a bit better i mean you can
see here it's coming it's it's about
the same speed as you could read at
least scan so
you know things coming out at that speed
is this
a little painful 9600 which we were
running uh
all our terminals in the math and
physics building
that's much better i mean you can see
that's coming out actually faster than
you can read
so that comes out at a reasonable rate
and you could actually do some things
with that
that was kind of the the backdrop to it
that uh
if you wanted to play any of these games
they because they all came out so slowly
there was very
you didn't want to print out a lot of
stuff on the screen because
uh he would take forever to display it
there was an adventure game
that people may well have come across
and that was all very text based
you know you're in the forest and you
don't go left or go
north or go south or into the building
and then it would
chunk through and say oh this describe
the scene and then it would abbreviate
the scene because
you didn't want to take all this time
showing the scene again because
it just takes so much time so that's
kind of where we
were at and say there was various games
you could play tic-tac-toe and
something called which i never really
understood some mystical thing
and uh there was a nice quiz game that
um
you could actually load a database so
you say
they have one state capitals and states
so what's the capital of new york and
things like that and you could play it
in either direction you could say
okay uh given given the capital what's
the state or
whatever and you could write new games
for that so that was quite fun and there
was a hangman game i
remember but they're all rather
poor and uh boring to some extent
and that's kind of the way it stayed
until we upgraded to uh
the next computer which was the vax 750
running berkeley 4.2 i think we've got
him we might have run one of the 4.1
versions berkeley 4.1 is that a
completely different kind of fork to
version 7 units yeah it was taken from
that so we have version 7 which only
really ran
on a few things so pvp 11's and
i think they've pulled it to a couple of
other things and then they
did get a vax at
bell labs and they did a quick port
which i think was called the 32v
32 bit version or something
and it was really just a straight pause
the pvp 1170 which had no virtual memory
so it was just wanted straight over and
so just
ran like a pdp 1170 but didn't use any
of the
extensions so you were still limited to
64k
programs but ken thompson went to
berkeley
and took version of it which is kind of
why berkeley got
involved he spent a year there as a
professor i think
and they just sort of descended on it
and said well we can do much better we
can actually
start using the virtual memory so we can
have programs as big as we like we can
we don't need to be constrained we can
have paging and all this sort of stuff
so
i think they started with a version two
on pdp elevens that didn't have virtual
memory then they
went to version four dots here
presumably that uh worked on the backs
with virtual memory
but crucially it had a new game um
and this was uh something called uh
rogue
uh which is uh subtitled exploring the
dungeons of doom
and this was came about by two uh
guys michael toy and glenn wichmann who
were working at
uh university california san diego i
believe
but they eventually moved up to
university of california berkeley
which was the people who produced this
4.2 so this game was around in the
atmosphere
and it got included into these
distributions
and it was based on something written by
ken arnold called the curses library
so you imagine the scene we're all
sitting at these terminals which are
just like
typewriters with screens attached but
there are all sorts of different ones so
we used tdi912s there were things called
vt-100s there's a hazel time
they're all much the same in if you just
printed characters to the screen
you printed a line of characters and
then a carriage returned line feed will
get you
to the next thing so scrolling up the
screen was easy
but they also had mechanisms to position
you at the screen so you could say go to
the home position or you could go to
an arbitrary position on the screen and
but they were all used very different
sort of character sequences to do that
so what worked on the tvi
i want to to put you to here would sort
of turn into gobble to google
something else so we had a few programs
that knew about this but they were all
sort of very hardwired i said what
turtle am i on there
i'm on a tbr 912 but i don't i know how
to get there
i want something else i've no idea how
to position myself to a
place in the screen but ken arnold came
up with a library
that knew how to position itself on
sort of pretty much any any terminal was
and uh had it had a database so you
could add new terminals to it
sort of mini programming language just
by linking with this library you could
say
in a terminal independent way go to this
location and draw something and it was
very
much optimized to work with 1200 and 300
board
terminals so that uh you've got a good
experience whatever so here is
rogue so what's happening here is you're
looking down on a
dungeon you're in a room here that's um
surrounded by these dashes
the doors are crosses the monsters are
capital letters so we've got a snake
there waiting to get to us
and we're the at character highlighted
and there's a bit of gold over there
that i can go and get you can see the
snake is after me
and i've got i'm on level one of the
dungeon now with 44 gold pieces
12 out of 12 hit points 16 out of 16
strength armor class 4
and no experience i can get some
experience by
attacking the speak all this snake is
attacking me though i've got
three points of experience so these two
guys
using this library they could actually
they'll get
to display on the screen anywhere you
could have this sort of adventure game
and you could actually move around the
screen and chase monsters and monsters
could chase you
and so on so it was a fantastic thing
so there we are i died never attack ice
monsters
we spent many hours on it it was also
procedurally generated
so each time you went into the dungeon
you got a new layout so you couldn't
learn it
as such you could learn what the monster
did and you could learn
what accessories were potions and
scrolls and things like this
and new weapons you could find so you
gradually built up
your own database in your head of what
was good and what was bad but you didn't
know what the dungeon was going to be
like
it was new each time uh you could save
your progress
but uh you couldn't copy the save file
and they made sure that so you could
restore it and carry on
but you couldn't cheat by saving
yourself and then trying something out
and if that went wrong go back to
position so they thought of that
so uh yes it was a fascinating thing and
really
changed things around a lot and i think
it's partly because of this curses
library
partly because the the board rates were
getting faster and you could actually
get
somewhat interactive at this point it's
really interesting the idea of
procedurally generated maps i believe
that elite on the bbc used procedurally
generated maps here
how might that work yeah elite is a
really good example because they tried
to cram
as many star systems into a world as
they could
but found you could just haven't got the
the uh
space to store all this so instead they
worked off something
procedurally generated so you take a
couple of numbers and you
do some arithmetic on it or something
and you get a sequence building up from
initial seed so you start with something
and multiply it by three
multiply it by three again or something
and you get a sequence of numbers and
then you
use those to map into sort of planets or
something like that
so rogue was very similar i mean it it
did have some rules
behind it it actually divided the screen
into sort of nine
sequel nine squares three by three
so you would probably have a room in
each of those three
squares and then they would be connected
by corridors but they would move around
within those boundaries
and sometimes it would miss out a room
so there wasn't actually a room there
was just a corridor that went through it
and do that so
yeah they played around with that and
they played around with lots of these
ideas
and um eventually also ken arnold who
did the
curses library came on board and helped
him
uh improve and uh i think he also did
quite a bit
extra work on the curses library so that
it would be sort of
optimal because there's more than one
way to get to a place on the screen if
you happen to be already
almost there you could just move across
a couple which would only be two
characters maybe
rather than maybe four characters to
jump to a specific location so you can
optimize things in that way so yes we
we played this rogue game for hour after
hour
after after hours in fact because you
weren't allowed to play games during the
day
um about 5 30
a script would run and games would be
turned on and
all descend on that i don't know anybody
who ever completed rogue
i think you have to get down to level 24
in the dungeon where you pick up an
amulet and come back and be the winner
i don't i think i got down to maybe
level 20 once that was as far as i ever
got
i don't know anybody else in the
department who
got much further than that and certainly
nobody completed it
there were stories on the internet of
people who completed it but
i've never met anyone who have so it was
a particularly tough game
so you know the first few levels were
quite easy
but after that it got progressively
harder
is it available as an emulator could be
black yeah i just had a look in fact you
can get it on steam there were versions
that they ported after the unix to
ms-dos and windows they were always
tinkering with the game
and a couple of reasons for this one was
just to make it a little bit more
exciting and
so on but there was also
another branch to this which i'll
perhaps talk about in the uh
next video we make of this where um
there are other ways of playing it so uh
i'll
just leave that there as a little taster
of what's to come
but uh yeah once once i'd discovered
this second
level i stopped playing the game and
went went to do something different
instead which uh we'll talk about next
time
if you do that this unix will get you
started
in the great world of multi-user on
simple terminals
you can do your own thing you'll run out
of steam after about four or five years
it's all done taken care of and julie on
the first of
uh april it came out as this ipv9